I'm going gene you back to gene we're
regressing with your style we're going
back to gene sandals no no I it's just
hot today and I threw him on in a hurry
that's all I won't wear pants with
sandals in my house
really nope really to get the mail like
that
what about Berks you go Bert you know
that's good she put out online he
wouldn't he bought a pair of boots with
a buckle on him from Gucci never warm
again you warm once I think right I wear
them all the time
you too father I'm not wear boots this
do we really
yeah have you ever tried Burke's
Birkenstock but you got a Berk to wait
for me nice tie you got a Burke coming
from me dude is different it's not like
flip-flops it's not like slides
it's bird that's wide open it's like a
combination he's got double straps you
actually feel you could do something you
could like you could fight if you need
like it's clear what can you run them
you need to get Burke's communist dude
is a communist why are those Burke's 503
hundred they're made to your foot nah
man I don't do din sandals just so no no
that's not saying you got to stop that's
Burke's that's different that guy looks
pretty cool hey that's it that be dude
that's refined what are you gonna wear
if you're in there's a bird inside
there's a Birkenstocks tour on a bikini
hey hey
so get them let's get you to my ears my
Tevas but don't wear though yeah I think
you can you're past that and you're more
refined than that yeah you're a Berk
you're you know yeah you lose me yeah
but you could Burke that's the thing
that you don't realize you can Burke and
my toes dog is different it's your toes
already been vulnerable and you start
not vulnerable summer's over bro look
I'm in the ledge
ugly the ledge protects your toe you see
at the front there's that little edge
you're not stubbing your toe not even
one time there are not even one time you
step in your toe and your heel there's
that little hook right there that's
daily like Jesus shoes yeah say what it
look like Jesus hey soos in an emergency
maybe but that is you never have animal
or sex it's a different life that's a
boat collared shirt huh - eunuch bro
that's too much that's too much that's
it that's a commitment that's too much
well yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]